- Hey, everyone.
I hope you're having an amazing day.
It's Mark Wiens.
I'm in Kuala Lumpur, Malaysia.
There's this one dish called tempoyak,
which his fermented durian,
which can be used to eat
as a condiment with rice, or
you can make it into a curry.
And ever since I heard
about this years ago,
it has been a mission, it's
been a dream of mine to go,
to come back to Malaysia,
and to eat it at the source.
And so today, we're driving to Temerloh
which is famous for a catfish.
It's along the river.
And they make a very, very famous,
it's known throughout Malaysia
for their catfish tempoyak,
durian, fermented durian curry.
So we're on our way.
We're gonna meet up with Sufian,
who also makes videos, food videos.
I cannot be,
my mouth is already watering.
I can't wait to share the
food with you right now.
(upbeat music)
Alright.
That was about an hour and a half drive.
Welcome to Temerloh.
But the ride and this entire
town is known for their durian,
or this entire area, known
especially for tempoyak
and also the freshwater catfish.
What's up, man?
- Great.
- [Mark] Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you too.
I'm super excited--
- [Mark] Thank you.
- To meet Mark Wiens.
- [Mark] Cool, man.
Awesome to meet you,
and awesome to meet you
to eat this special delicacy.
- Yeah.
This is the special, what
we call patin tempoyak.
- [Mark] Patin tempoyak.
- Yeah.
- They have some little to-go tubs
of fermented durian as well.
Oh, that sounds delicious.
They have salads.
They have fried meats,
fried chicken, fried fish.
Ah, so you can walk down
the line and check on it,
just grab what you want
and then put it on your
tray and self seating.
At the end of the line is
where they serve the main dish,
the curry, the tempoyak
curry with the catfish.
And as soon as he stirred that, you can,
just the poof of steamy humidity of durian
just filled this entire
little back room back here.
We asked it,
Sufian asked them for extra spicy.
So he took a spoon of extra
chili before he added it.
First they have, it looks
like they have the fish
cooked on its own, and then the main sauce
which is in a separate pan
which they then combine.
And then you take that on your tray
and bring it to your table, ready to eat.
(upbeat music)
I think facing this way should
be really good if we all sit.
It has an incredible aroma.
You can smell it's like sour and fruity.
- Yup, and--
- And you can smell the fermented--
- Fermented--
- [Mark] For sure.
- [Sufian] Fermented durian for sure.
- This is one of those dishes,
one of those foods where I'm
like shaking in anticipation.
I just can't wait.
- [Joel] Oh, yeah.
- This is the essence.
- Ah, this is sambal tempoyak.
- [Sufian] Can you smell it?
- Wow.
(Sufian chuckles)
Oh, that smells incredible.
That's like durian plus like oniony.
- [Sufian] Onion, yes.
- [Mark] Plus--
- [Sufian] Chili.
- Chili, jungley.
- Ooh.
(Mark laughs)
Powerful.
- It's powerful.
The head is the super spicy.
He added in an entire
extra spoon of chili.
And then this one is the normal.
The tail is the normal spiciness.
- [Mark] It's like thick.
- [Sufian] Very think.
- [Mark] Almost like,
yeah, like liquid fruit.
- Cheers.
(Mark chuckles)
- Oh, wow.
Oh.
- You can taste the
chili inside your mouth.
It's burning.
- Damn, it's spicy, but it's so rich.
- It's spicy because
we got the extra spicy,
but then the actual tempoyak,
it does have a fruity,
almost like pineappley taste to it.
Actually, maybe even the durian,
the aroma is stronger than the
taste for the actual durian.
That is unbelievably good,
like the perfect balance
of sour, fermented and spicy all together.
I've only had one bit, and
that's a life-changing dish.
(Sufian laughs)
- That's true, man.
(Mark laughs)
- Okay, we're gonna move
into the actual fish now.
I'll start with the head
because I gotta go for that spiciness.
And dip in, get as much gravy
as possible, onto my rice,
load that up with some
more tempoyak gravy.
Alright, mix in, get that fish.
You can see the skin as well,
the meat mixed in with your rice.
Oh, wow.
It's such a,
it's like the fruitiest
curry you will ever have.
How is it, man?
- Mmm.
Superb.
You can taste the tempoyak
more in the sambal.
- In the sambal, okay.
- In the sambal, yeah.
- 'Cause that's like the
condensed version of it.
- Yup, it's very thick.
- This looks like a perfect
leaf to scoop it up.
It's just like the custard of durian
just with extra fermented
layers of flavor.
Oh. (laughs)
Oh, that's--
- Very good, right?
- Oh, that's incredible.
Oh, wow.
Yeah, that is the more condensed version.
You definitely feel the durian.
The durian like goes up
your nose a little bit.
I've had variations of veggies
and dip around the world,
but that takes the crown
for being the ultimate
vegetables and dip that
you could possibly have.
That is just flavor overload.
(Joel laughs)
- Ooh.
- This looks like a watercress kind of.
You're gonna lick your fingers
after that, guaranteed.
That is finger-licking,
that is the definition
of finger-licking good.
- [Joel] Immediately, it smells amazing.
(Sufian laughs)
- [Mark] We've got one more dish.
Pais patin.
- Pais patin.
- Bakar.
- [Mark] So it's the same fish.
- [Sufian] Yup, same fish.
- And so what they do for this dish
is they put it in the tempoyak.
- Tempoyak, yes.
- Then they wrap it in a banana leaf.
- In the banana leaf.
And then they, what we call, grill it.
- And then grill it.
So all the like tempoyak,
durian, fermented flavors
just soak into the fish as it grills.
Yeah, you can just see just
the puddingness of that gravy,
of that sauce, that tempoyak.
Mix it up with the rice, mix the fish.
Unwrapping a gift will never
be the same again. (laughs)
This is the best gift you
could ever receive (laughs),
a packet of tempoyak.
Okay, guys.
This one is even more fruity.
It's like a condensed
tempoyak fruitiness version.
Wow.
We've also got some pickled petai,
which are stink beans, stinky beans.
They smell beautiful
and a totally different,
unique aroma than the tempoyak.
Awesome, and these guys are fermented too.
It's called petai jeruk.
- [Sufian] Petai jeruk.
- Petai jeruk.
Oh, yeah. (laughs)
- The smell is so dope. (laughs)
- Oh.
It's like a vitamin.
- Ooh.
(Mark laughs)
- It's an unexplainable flavor.
It's a sensation.
It's an experience in
your mouth is what it is.
- The taste is so strong.
Wow.
- That's one of those things
where the aftertaste keeps on giving.
- Wow.
- It's pungent and so good.
(upbeat music)
- [Joel] That smells beautiful.
- That is an explosive bite.
Oh, wow, the flavor is,
it's almost so unique
that there's nothing to compare it to.
It's its own.
From the assembly line,
we got the masak lemak,
which is beef.
This is beef with curry
in coconut milk, curry.
Oh, that's stunning too.
That is like beef jerky in
like a spicy coconut milk,
like rich curry sauce.
Ah, (mumbles) okay.
So there's onions,
there's shallots in here.
There's some herbs.
There's coconut, right?
- [Sufian] Coconut, yeah.
- Oh, oh, that's wonderful.
All the crisp vegetables and herbs,
all just coated in like dried coconut.
That is a gravy of wonders.
I don't know if gravy will ever be
the same again in my life.
Oh, we have dessert now. (laughs)
- Cendol durian.
- [Mark] What's all in there?
The green noodles.
Is there ice cream?
- [Sufian] Cendol.
- Those are like the pandan noodles.
- Pandan noodles, yeah.
- Okay.
- And then we have, this one is red beans.
- [Mark] Red beans.
- [Sufian] Red beans.
- [Mark] Okay.
- [Sufian] And then we have a gula Melaka.
It's actually already melted.
- [Mark] Ah, the sugar.
It's like a brown sugar.
- [Sufian] Brown sugar.
- [Mark] From Melaka?
- [Sufian] Gula Melaka, yeah.
- [Mark] Which is very
famous in Melaka, right?
- Yeah.
- And then there's an entire
chunk, ice cream in there.
- [Sufian] Ice cream.
- [Mark] Ice cream and ice.
- [Sufian] Ice cream and ice.
- [Mark] And that's what makes--
- [Sufian] Shredded ice.
- Shredded ice.
No other dessert would do.
The only thing that could top
this is a stinky bean cendol.
(Sufian and Mark laugh)
(upbeat music)
- [Sufian] Wow.
- [Mark] How was that, dude?
- This durian is superb.
Wow.
I'm speechless right now. (chuckles)
- It almost has the effect
of a root beer float.
You know, when the foam,
because of the carbonation and
then the ice cream, the foam.
The durian and the ice cream
is having that same effect.
Oh, wow.
Yeah, that durian is--
- [Sufian] So big.
- [Mark] Unbelievably good.
It's so creamy.
It's so sweet.
It's like half frozen
because of the ice, right?
- [Sufian] Yeah.
- [Mark] So it's like
very cold and refreshing.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] What was your name?
- Rizar, Rizar.
- [Mark] Rizar.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] (speaks in foreign
language) It's amazing food,
amazing food.
- Yeah, thank you.
- What is it called?
Like when you're playing a video game
and you go to the next level,
that's like going to the
next level of cuisine.
Since we're in Temerloh, we've decided
to go try one more
restaurant that also serves
the same dish, the fish with tempoyak.
This is a tempoyak town.
But since we just happened to be here.
Okay, so we're on our way
to go try one more tempoyak
restaurant. (laughs)
- That was life changing.
- Yes.
- Using durian as a cooked
ingredient was life changing.
- Fermented cooked ingredient.
(Joel laughs)
Just about a 10-minute
drive just down the river.
And this is another very local restaurant
to eat tempoyak plus the same catfish.
We've just arrived.
It's really in the neighborhood.
You're actually backed into the jungle.
You almost come back into the plantations,
the fruit plantations,
and it looks like it's
in somebody's front yard.
This really is like in somebody's home.
So they have their home,
the whole compound,
and then they open up the line of food.
Again, you smell the tempoyak,
that durian, fruity, sour aroma.
(woman speaks in foreign language)
Round number two.
- [Joel] Oh, the precious cargo.
Just as excited.
- And then over here is
where you scoop out your,
it's all self service,
scoop out your own rice.
Okay, we got the tempoyak curry.
We got our own plates
of rice and vegetables.
We've got some tea.
We're all set for round two.
And I'm really loving the
environment, the atmosphere here.
It's very laid back.
Same setup. (laughs)
- Same setup.
- [Mark] We've got the tempoyak.
We've got--
- [Sufian] Patin tempoyak, the same fish.
- The same fish, the bakar.
- [Sufian] The pais patin.
- I think in English, it's
called a silver catfish.
So it is a type of catfish.
Taste the curry, taste the broth.
Oh, an the owner, he hooked us up
with a whole bowl full
of just the extra gravy.
- [Sufian] Extra gravy.
- I think the first step
is just to taste the gravy
just to get the full
effect and taste of it.
Oh. (laughs)
Oh, wow.
I had a little drop go down onto my lap.
Yeah, this one is almost really mangoey.
- [Sufian] Mangoey.
- [Mark] Like it's mangoey.
- [Sufian] Yeah.
This one is less thicker than the--
- [Mark] The previous one that we tried.
But this one is nice
and spicy, and this one,
you can actuallY feel like the chili
burning your lips a little
bit, like that first bite.
- The first bite.
- That's amazing.
That is unbelievably good. (laughs)
And just the yellowness of it.
Look how orange-yellow
it is with the turmeric.
- -[Sufian] Spicier than before.
- [Joel] More spicy.
- Yeah, it is more spicy.
And that is, it really,
truly is one of the
world's greatest flavors.
I don't say that lightly.
It reveals, it opens up your taste buds
that you didn't even think you had.
The skin is part of the
highlight of eating this fish
because it has a totally
different texture to it.
Stick some of this on to the,
oh, yes.
He knew we wanted extra
gravy before we even started.
That gravy goes so well with the rice.
Like liquid fermented durian.
Life doesn't get better,
under a mango tree.
I don't know if life can
get better than this.
This is as good as eating gets.
The sambal tempoyak.
- Ooh.
- Oh, it sticks to the lid.
That's a beautiful sight.
Oh, look at the stickiness of that.
Lumpy. (laughs)
oh, that smells so good.
Oh, yeah.
That is not, that's not an
aroma for the faint of heart.
(Sufian laughs)
Just as I was leaving the
buffet line, I found the jenkol,
but I'm gonna dip it
into the durian sambal.
I don't know if you can dream
of a better combination.
Cheers.
- Ready, guys?
- (laughs) Jenkol.
- Jenkol cheers.
(Mark laughs)
Oh, that one almost tastes like cheese.
And the jenkol is very, very young,
so it's very soft and chalky.
Yeah, you feel the chalkiness
coating your mouth.
And for the bakar, I'm gonna unwrap this.
This is the grilled fish.
Oh, we got the head.
You can actually see the like,
the tempoyak starting to
ooze, ooze out of the packet.
Oh, wow.
That sauce is so thick.
It's like a jam.
I'm gonna take a little bit of this.
- Wow.
That is,
oh, yes, I saw the finger lick.
- Finger-licking good.
- It's not, it's totally
okay to lick your fingers?
- Yup.
- Oh, good, 'cause you, like
the natural human thing to do
would be lick your fingers immediately.
It's that tasty.
It really almost has
like an apricot mango flavor, mango puree.
- [Sufian] This is the best part.
- [Mark] The belly part,
fish belly tempoyak.
- [Sufian] Full of collagen.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- [Sufian] Full of collagen here.
- [Mark] Collagen and durian.
Wow, look at that oiliness.
Give that a dip.
Dip it into... (chuckles)
- [Mark And Sufian] Oh!
- [Mark] That is the bite.
- Oh, my goodness.
(Mark laughs)
Oh.
- [Mark] Your reaction
was just too tempting.
And I like that they filled
tempoyak into the whole fish.
Look at that.
It's like a stuffed, it's
stuffed with tempoyak.
Look at that goo.
- [Joel] Wow, dipping jelly.
- Oh. (laughs)
Oh, wow.
That just oils in your mouth.
The belly just starts to melt
and then like the fruity
pulpiness of that tempoyak.
That's unexplainable delicious.
It's polite to lick your
fingers here, it's okay?
- [Sufian] Yeah.
- Okay.
There's a reason they
don't have napkins here.
It's because you're gonna wanna lick,
you have to lick your fingers.
No napkins on the table,
and no napkins necessary.
Let's go with the jenkol scoop.
Yeah, I mean, the deliciousness
of this meal is just,
it's no exaggeration.
No facial expression, no
descriptive vocabulary
can possibly do the food justice.
- [Sufian] Sambal tempoyak.
- Sambal tempoyak.
Then I also got some eggplant.
Almost actually the
same texture as durian.
It's just like custardy, like pudding.
It just kinda melts in your mouth.
You can taste a lot of garlic in that too.
It just (laughs),
this is one of the
hardest meals to explain,
not because of the, I mean,
not only because the flavor
is so complex, but because
it's so unbelievably good,
your brain cannot process
how good it is and cannot,
your taste buds can't,
here, okay, I got it down.
When it hits your taste buds,
your brain doesn't have
the capacity to explain
how good it tastes, and
I will leave it at that.
And I expected it to be
good because I love durian.
I love spicy.
- Spicy, yeah.
- But that like blew my expectations
way over, multiple times.
That really is one of the greatest dishes,
like flavor, powerful
dishes that I've ever had.
But I wanna say a huge
thank you to Sufian for--
- [Sufian] Thank you very much.
- For coming with us, for helping us.
He's amazing to hang out with and eat.
His channel is called Padu Beb Studios.
- Yeah.
- He travels.
He makes videos about food and travel.
Your videos are in Malay, Bahasa Malay.
- [Sufian] In Malay language.
- [Mark] But you have English subtitles.
- [Sufian] English subtitles, yeah.
- So I will have his channel
in the description box below.
Go check it out, subscribe to him.
He's just a lot of fun
to hang out with and eat.
And yeah, thank you, man.
- Thank you.
(Mark speaks in foreign language)
Thank you very much, man.
- And thank you for watching this video.
Please remember to give it a
thumbs up if you enjoyed it.
Leave a comment below.
I'd love to hear from you.
And if you're not already
subscribed, click subscribe now.
And also, click the little bell icon.
You get notified of the
next video that I publish.
Thanks again for watching.
Goodbye from Temerloh.
(Sufian speaks in foreign language)
(Mark speaks in foreign language)
- Yeah.
- From the epicenter of tempoyak.
See you on the next video.